absolutely Irina congratulations welcome
back to the studio it felt like the
results the decisive results were just
about ready to show on your boards and
finally they did you scored a hat trick
you scored the three decisive results
three wins how do you feel right now and
what changed in your play yeah so well
that's the thing nothing
matter of you know
um playing a little bit better and maybe
getting a little bit luckier
um
um and yeah and I do like I said I feel
like I've been playing better every
round and uh this game was kind of a
pleasant surprise you know when you get
to attack like that it's kind of
inspiring because you don't win in a
like a routine way but you actually you
know I think G5 was a really interesting
uh Pawn sack going all the way maybe we
can talk about sorry sorry to interrupt
you Fabiano caruana I just won his game
against elshon moriada yapadi and
extends his lead at the top
yeah so when she let me play this move
C5 right I thought okay that's you know
black has delayed developing this Knight
for way too long right she could have
played Knight D7
uh yeah 97.
um okay that's that structure position
yeah of course it's uh it's nice for
whites but you know when she when she
played A5 I was like you know I can
actually do better than that and C5
looks like really interesting because
actually I have Bishop A3 ideas so she
it's very hard for her to kick back with
the queen
now if she takes then that's what
happens in the game right but like in
general like if she goes like Knight C6
and I take right she can't take with the
queen because of this so this little
detail is not helpful for black and if
she takes with a c Pawn I mean I just
thought the position after C4 honestly
was pretty bad and I mean yes it's kind
of playable but like I was even looking
at ideas here like Knight F3 to D2 to B1
to C3 as like the best Square for the
night and just stay in that position
because it's pretty I mean it seems kind
of bad in terms of the pawn structure
for black here
um but what she went for I guess is even
worse yeah like she took on C5 yeah and
this position was you know quite quite
amazing for white but I I think I
deserve a beating for this F1 move it
was such a bad bad positional move
actually and I I think I just got over
excited about my position like I just
was like oh this looks nice for me but
of course if you just think about the
big picture like you have the center you
have the bishop pair so why my trading
pieces why am I changing the pawn
structure
um yeah I think F4 I wasn't uh in
hindsight wasn't too happy with that but
still even after F4 you do uh keep some
of your advantage and definitely this
very nice center right that became
decisive in the game Knight takes C5 and
then you play this move Bishop to F4
Rook 28 and G4 yeah so let me tell you a
little bit here like I mean I just
realized it wasn't so easy for me to win
with this big sensor right that I'd been
counting on like if I go D4 there's
always Bishop C4
um my Pawn can't really move to D5 and
like
um yes I wasn't sure how I was going to
proceed here so then I was like well let
me try this G4 idea like maybe somewhere
I can play G5 like
um it is kind of like part of the board
where I can do something on and after
she played Knight f8 uh Bishop E3 B6 and
I was like again I was kind of stuck for
a move
and and then and then this this idea hit
me like I can just sack the pawn to make
sure the diagonal is always open and G5
is
um under pressure and then I can go in
the center and this is that's actually
probably the best thing that I came up
with in the game because it really
accelerated the win right you can just
tell it like it was a turning point and
after this point like okay somehow the
game went smoothly you know I despite
the computer's evaluation like I never
felt any trouble again in this game you
felt like the pressure is piling up and
your opponent is it was really hard for
her I mean to figure out like you know
what to do with the Knight to protect
the G5 Pawn or nods and and the center
now was kind of Untouchable you know
yeah absolutely and the were there any
critical moments after this one or you
just felt like I mean over here actually
wait one second Christian I was
wondering if I could sag The Exchange I
was like can I just go what's the F1 but
then I realized you know after Bishop F5
and pawn takes she always has these F6
ideas and actually my pawns they could
get a little bit stuck so yeah I have to
say this is very tempting seeing D5 E5
and F5 yeah I thought that was stylish
but you know then I was like I don't
really need this because I can just move
my Rook
um and and then basically she has a
tough time defending this F7 pawn and
once I take it then it's just like a
matter of you know not blundering
anything and winning with the queen and
the pawns absolutely Irina
congratulations uh three out of three in
the last uh three rounds congratulations
go get some rest and we'll see you in
the remainder of your games thank you
Christian well done well done Arena
three in a row indeed